it's not quite a nation we did that with
meditation no you're David you a person
doesn't really know what he's looking
for mr. Daley he tries to kind of deep
focus his concentration and basically
what kind of flows because you know
whatever state is in here it is the
opposite lateral qabalah has very of
them specific accurate definitions of
how you should kind of focus your mind
so you penetrate matter so you begin to
feel the forces school the forces that
stand behind our matter hush bug with
that those are forces of love and bestow
forces of bonding and unity verena damn
live nation so before personally Leo to
Hubert Michael potato bonds for these
forces I should work on in the South
elevate himself above his ego very busy
to give me ideas and our special
exercises to do those relates to the
environment that you have to build an
environment that it increases your
importance of rising above 10 that you
have to start considering and
appreciating being considered to order a
social dog so you reach or achieve this
rule that is the basicity rule can
choose area that I can offer that that
is in every room faith which is love
dear friend and a neighbor as thyself